evening all I'm with my good friend
Chris known as chess explain we're going
to have a look at now Game four of the
rapids so 25 minutes each with a 10
second increments / move and I'm plain
white girlfriend blac hi Chris yeah
hello for the final game and
everything's set here for 4 showdown as
the standing before this game was two to
one in Allen's favor the defending
champion so the Challenger girl phone
needed to win this game at all costs a
draw it's not not acceptable so the same
he needs to win ya to care to even the
score and get to the yeah further blitz
games that then what would come up Lou
so it's the most difficult thing to do
when against the super strong opponent
again with black and the opponent only
needs to draw himself so move very
difficult task let's see him yeah what
he came up with two to try this so I'm
yeah you see again place you form and
then again we have this special ich
hoffe invitation no no no we don't have
a supposed to cope we have d6 bother me
yeah d six instead of noise these things
yeah first of all first a quick quick
mentioned that Anand goes for you for
which is just a better move to play for
a draw so first well he played you for a
couple of games we wanted to win I guess
but if i was just a better move if you
want to really yeah get the game into
something very very dry so let's see
what happens so d6 yeah this is already
quite some invitation to the night off
which girlfriend to see you check
spurred on hmm but it it's declined with
Bishop b5 check yes so the same Rosalie
my Bishop b5 but a different position
not pinning night or anything so what do
you think about Bishop b5 is it really a
drawing weapon against d6
no it'sit's it user usually leads to
position that I'm not so so sharp in
contrast to the open decision of course
but it's really a bit of a madam how
wide continues what kind of sub
variations he will choose some are in
fact quite lame and bit boring but you
can you can perfectly play this move to
to play for an advantage it's less sharp
than before but not necessarily worse
certainly a move that can be recommended
to players who look for some rather
interesting game still but don't want to
really get into this huge body of t4
theory so it's not not bad back then
when I still play D for like 15 years
ago I also played this actually this was
the line I beat my first international
master with white yeah when I still play
d4 it's a long time ago okay so um and
and I didn't necessarily play this to do
to play for a draw i also want some
games ok so I'm girl phone plays the
most frightening movie in 97 another
move on to sort of try to unbalance it's
96 which I also played myself as black
ah i actually prefer 96 there but ok
it's a matter of taste the main point is
that Bishop d7 in comparison you just
look at this briefly this is some this
kind of this kind of position is much
harder for black to to try to play for
when you as some very often I'm not sure
God the move over here this year and
then stuff like c 3 and d for let's say
line like this here you just just to
show it briefly oops 94 and I think
vishu wouldn't in a million years lose
this position you just pile up on the C
file and it's difficult to do anything
this kind of somewhat lame position hmm
um might arise on white also might go
for some Murat see blind kind of
structure after 27 here um I don't
really handle this well this kind of
move and it's also difficult to to do
anything with black let's say stuff like
this and then why it sets up the murat
see blind and it's not much reflect to
do besides e65 tried to equalize and
equal is not good for black here see so
in this match situation so he went on I
to g7 which is really the fighting move
funny enough to move firm also a non
played like about two months ago in the
german bundesliga against the Grand
Master Chief Yakov was black and he lost
horribly hunt so yeah some here's some
memories about this position not so
pleasant once from blacks point of view
okay so let's see what happens here um I
actually forgot what I was played a key
for you before now Knight f6 just
hitting Ephraim return I think now
there's a surprising move quick a5 it
looks as though White's playing forcing
moves here without cancelling even and
yeah it was think that yeah the first
impression was that there might be some
rather forcing line here which sort of
kills all active play here to to get a
draw maybe otherwise this movie says
uncommon really um wide usually I think
just castles nice but it's um it's not
like that i know this too well i think
you can actually a often see for thorn
hmm let's let's say something like this
Yemm is quite risky obviously if you
look at this what is what is black doing
here it's see we will have lots of
problems
you think I think you cannot even take
but um okay we're getting far away from
the game but this would be the move to
to get a fight here usually a position
like this comes up in this line right
and white will capture on this end at
some point and play see form mm being
very solid of course but this is also a
position where blacken can fight for
something young it's a typical imbalance
bone structure typical of the night or
form of this rationing curve so it
looked like me she just wanted to yeah
to somehow simplify immediately mm-hmm
and the amazing thing here I'm sorry I'm
the amazing thing here is some girl fans
time usage again I think at this point
he invested like three minutes or
something i'm not sure but quite quite
something I think what what he tried um
was to try to spot them what kind of
forcing line is coming up here um in
order to really avoid a complete trade
of pieces because it needs to have some
things on the board left to play for win
but Queen a five he played and this
looks like the move you would play
instantly actually check right she told
ya so 22 minutes down to 22 there on
this relay simulation check oh yeah
about three minutes yeah I was quite
surprised that she took some time but
it's a bit it's understandable in a way
because really need to check that you
don't run into some some prepared
drawing line and of course this is
unacceptable so it needs to have some
kind of tension on the board so of
course nice III you need to keep your
pareo bishop yes and then nitey form
right yes moving a piece twice's is
breaking up beginners rule but it's sort
of justified here there's a fret of
night takes and Queen tanks b5
potentially I'm not forcing white spy
Bishop d7 perhaps but now what is white
plate plays Bishop d2
so so now this is interesting so black
is faced with a bishop takes a Knight
takes e4 as a threat to win apiece so
what it's like do here yeah I think what
happens so now looks um yeah almost
forced and maybe you can consider taking
on d 2 oh well it took on c3 but let's
say you would take on d 2 mm justice for
instance um and this is looks dangerous
you don't have a good development here
the new normal move would be Queen d2
maybe even like you to come to
consideration but now you don't have
anything developed at all so what do you
do now I mean there are things may be
coming up like let's say let's say black
we play a move like g6 here too hmm to
try to develop you what do you what do
you do now let's say this and rookie
want to come and you basically busted
immediately so I think you cannot afford
ready to take on on d 2 mmm you have
lost so much time already yeah and to
think you need to really play what what
what your tea did she took on c3 yes and
this forces y22 kept showing this
happiness dunno the bishop is hanging
you and this also speeds up legs
development a bit here you went um yeah
and the good thing here for black is
some you've got a very nice control here
after of the light squares this kind of
losses in c 6 spot assaults it always
very sensitive in these positions um so
it's very good that you have this Bishop
which is unopposed in general black
black God's like Scott the Jewish appeal
also and here's an interesting point
because I was actually a bit surprised
but he played no not that it is a bad
move but I thought the other one was was
just better but ok matter of taste maybe
so I'm Jeff on now went Queen a six yes
stopping when hosting King saw it yeah
actually okay I apologize I think I'm
I confused something but then it's the
next move which surprised me maybe okay
so yeah why does a bit uncomfortable
here with not able to castle and the
thing is looking at this position this
is not a fast draw at all I'd ever think
that why just managed to accomplish this
giving up the bishop pair for nothing
hmm so I think Calvin was should should
be and was pretty happy with his chance
iam um yeah yeah takes on d6 yep he
actually is an interesting position um
because at the end Black took on d6 what
an interesting move here to consider
would be it would be long castle alright
yes want to just get the pressure yeah
this is so yeah this would be
interesting trying to speed up
development I don't think white can
can't afford a move like this here and
then you've got rook e8 coming yeah if
if white tries to play play move like
this year to get rid of the Queen's you
always have this move will gets very
vicious very quickly yeah with this guy
uncensored yeah why does what I think
white white loses yeah yeah you cannot
you cannot get out of this mess and also
this Queen a success is super annoying
if you consider let's say I don't know a
variation like this year where why tries
to escape you also have for half a to
hanging here hmm this is a very very
annoying yeah so um yeah Dwight Dwight
would be in trouble of his too greedy so
he needs to come up with some other move
here and I'm not quite sure what smooth
should be it doesn't look like White has
a move he really likes to play small I
curve he is forced to do something that
he really didn't didn't intend be fine I
think that's an interesting alternative
yeah yeah absolutely yeah it's not on my
mind office will I suggested this so
before someone
successor I'm taking credit for this
interesting idea but I think at the end
he just decided to recapture which isn't
bad at all you've got two bishops hmm
and okay and now we need to yeah so this
the interesting possibility i mentioned
was this long casa lighters and
remembered something wrong the
difference now is that actually hear the
Queen's come off yeah that's a major
thing isn't it yeah that would have been
a major difference major together now
now fishy might have been relieved to
get the Queen's off a little bit less
less tension in the position that's
complexity anyway well it's hard to tell
it's a pretty it's a pretty
uncomfortable end game mmm I think the
only question in this end game here ok
let's okay first of all let's take him
and consider the next couple of moves
here so the only question this position
is slightly better for black or is it
already clearly better for black this is
the only only question here and of
course it's not the kind of position
that I don't want it here as he said in
the press conference he sort of said his
mind before this game to not play for a
draw to ya to too stubborn leads to so
trying to play a normal game play solid
yeah and save but simply a normal game
and as he said in the press conference
he awfully they're awfully um yeah
didn't follow his own his own idea of
course he knows that he shouldn't play
too too hard for a draw and now he got
cut himself into this rather
uncomfortable position oh by the way
Chris some you know he had this rapid
against Kasparov in Credit Suisse many
years back welker's provost blunder he
was talking about in chess based
magazine and he said for those games he
would rather play quickly and badly
rather than well and slowly said that
back then you know when he beats pawn
off yeah that was quite interesting so
maybe he's you know bit of the same
strategy as well he doesn't you know
he's prepared to sacrifice quality to
play quickly
oh yeah this that's true I bet I think
he maybe it just confused something or
whatever I think I mean I'm pretty much
sure if he if he plays this position
let's say ten times against top
opposition he will lose like four or
five and drop and draw a couple that you
would never win a game and you would
suffer suffer terribly I I think he must
have confused maybe something in his
preparation or no idea I'm just
speculating here because it's just a
childhood position hmm I mean it's just
just suffering for for nothing and yeah
but the thing is okay he got himself
into some some trouble here but looking
at the game it I think he did a very
good job to keeping his stuff together
and defending it's a great defender yeah
okay so um let's continue here um I
actually didn't remember what would like
played f6 yeah s6 me okay which okay it
belongs to Bishop times you on the
diagonal and gives the King 10th year
square if you need it once check check
using that light squared Bishop but it's
subject to a tempo again later
potentially so bishop well see now it
moves out the way anyway so that is that
is nice that bishop is having good time
at the moment yeah rook the one not
minding the double porns that will get
rid of blacks bishop pair and maybe some
dynamic compensation I guess yeah this
would spoil everything if you take on f3
hmm so what leg or black tries to do
here in in general is if you got the two
bishops and in this pin this kind of
position words it's not really dead open
already yeah the position is not so open
what you're trying to do is to gain
space ideally on both flanks on it was
possibly moves like g5 h5 and also be 5
a-5 basically what Galvan doesn't the
game we want to gain space and try to
open up the position slowly or not not
like possibly open it up like let's say
move like see txt for will just be
terrible yeah because the night it's got
good squares
five yeah yeah you want to do improve
slowly and trying to make slow progress
here maybe get rid of one rook hmm not
too maybe just one rook and and progress
slowly I think it did a good job only at
some point maybe black could have could
have played better if I remember this
correctly from watching the game life
you know it well it wasn't like black
mr. forcing winner or something but
somehow um it wasn't wasn't exactly
exactly enough what he played okay so
I'm I don't know what photo Sky King our
caking see one okay so Bishop e7 d5 so
at least the bishops not torturing white
now on the diagonal d7 but it can come
now to this diagonal potentially yeah
there should be two be five which is
like why it's being given a hard time
now on this side of the board there's
lots of targets isn't that what there's
a target picking slowly you can compress
the a free form of be4 first then play a
four to create fixed target of this a to
and that's what he does I think soon he
plays be4 first so but white is now
doubling on this e fo and this rook
might even be useful on the third rank
at some point and I know but on the
e-file I think he wanted to keep control
of the e6 square so that bishops kind of
has to maintain e6 this f5 might be a
bit ambitious I'm not totally sure yeah
I'm not sure it was well I think I am I
know that during the game that I
expected bishop f8 to be played and I
think this was also the methods that
Svidler wanted to play to get rid of one
pair of rooks and then really slowly
trying to improve the position because
doesn't this move improve the bishop
it's got tats cool target if white
doubles there's like a tactic like
Bishop takes g7 then you know if the
Kings having to protect you know it
starts to get some pressure points this
bishop oh yeah yeah this is one thing
and the other thing is you always have
to be very cautious with your pawn moves
this is the the old saying they cannot
cannot come back here yeah and is locked
in an ownership as well but yeah this is
good exactly this is the point at this
point you're sort of maybe improved your
e7 Bishop a bit you know it has got a
little bit more breathing space now but
potentially this d7 Bishop can be a very
bad piece and maybe maybe it was better
how to tell to to actually play really
this first bishop javaid you know let's
say something like this year yeah and
then trying to improve further nadra yet
I think this would exchange too much
pieces because very often it's useful to
keep one look here because why do you
read luke is not doing anything at the
moment you know it's not the threatening
piece yeah and if you imagine later
after it once in your pawns it's it's
very likely that that black will be the
yeah Adam the player here which we
initiate in this hour sorry who
initiates the opening of the position
and then you can really adjust your
exposition accordingly to to the exact
position where you open it up yeah so
it's very helpful to keep one rook
because this rook is more than attacking
piece potentially later then it would it
then it's um a hub for wide so it's um
this is always very tricky to challenge
should they exchange everything here and
so on but I think it's good to do keep
exactly one rookie I'm rule so and then
then maybe trying to improve very slowly
like moose at g 6 and so on what white
could could try to do is I'm not sure if
you will manage but what you could try
to do is I'm goat up some play maybe
against d 6 which is the only is a
strategic target but at the moment I was
difficult to sort of access it 94th
without any coordination on d6 unless
this Bishop because
somehow but in the meantime blacks
fixing this target he could work like
this with his rook to improve this yeah
um I think at the end the opening of the
the position must must come on the Kings
side hmm but down yeah it's difficult
you need to just play on very slowly
improving a bit and so on this it's not
a lot of position you can really analyze
so this concrete move some looks maybe
this was more flexible let's say yeah it
looks very committal this f5 it looks as
though and I must have been pleased with
f5 seeing our five plate because already
it looks it looks good there's an
immediate fret Bishop takes g7 here and
rook takes e7 now yeah deck needs to
attend to this so g5 it's like you know
what's happening to his King here
playing g5 it's like was he playing on
this side and then put on this side okay
in general this is because this is the
right strategy that the question is just
oh this is the right timing this is
maybe a bit too good to ya to quickly
play young so that you may be needed
some preparation for us also you see
this position if you would imagine this
kind of configuration with f5 and g5
yeah just imagine this position with
without this and this piece this would
would diminish White's counterplay
immensely you just got one rook here
because then you could I think easily
cover all this stuff yes and here you're
sort of tied up a bit yeah yeah so it
maybe it was really better to take off
to take off 11 rook yeah difficult
difficult to say but I think now she
really got some grip to the position and
consolidated nicely c4 okay which okay
so be four but this pawn chains quite
good for sealing d6 okays deprive
themselves of a nice night square but
this pawn chain looks impressive sort of
with the space wise now g3 discouraging
maybe f4 from black and maybe
okay so Bishop II Bishop goes to f8 then
we saw an exchange of rooks okay but
here the big difference the rook maybe
it's got a six now that weakness of the
last move yeah exactly but black
wouldn't play rookie a doll so this just
would go to exchange too many pieces so
um alright but what would happen if
rookie night um it's just there wouldn't
be a black eye for would be hopeless
without a rope behind it I guess yeah
you don't have to John you just don't
have have enough here so maybe just just
put on those you can put this on quickly
here that's it takes yeah now how would
you take now with the King maybe even
okay um not sure let's say we take with
the King and get another question is so
I should should white continue here 11
concrete thing as this move right yeah
and let's say something like this yeah
this looks ugly after this you can shake
cancel because also king of those bishop
the answer is also spot during the
stream that this a five could be a
target to Bishop the eighth of the KO
uff for you I'm not sure alright this is
jasmine just securing the draw as this
is close to a fortress here hmm you just
put in some peace on f4 and and then
it's over so um this is this is not
enough yeah you cannot exchange too much
so so you take you took what with the
bishop and then as you said yeah this
kind of moose also force unfortunately
Kings getting tangled up in the
variations there always it shouldn't
have been this unsafe this King it was
weird now this Kings oh it's gonna get
mated or something you know yet in the
sixth red blue if Y if black would have
one extra moves like Bishop 27 then all
this wouldn't be happening and
everything ok he really went for this
somewhat crazy looking King walk to
confuse matters
there's light squares to sort of
infiltrate on yeah yeah so H free
stopping the King using g4 but now g4
looks as though you know is amazing that
being instructed potentially so Bishop
f7 now rook f6 I can starting to look
quite nasty for black here so what does
he do about this has to protect f5 and
now we see rook e6 so there's already a
draw invitation for repetition you'll
just repeat yeah of course so what they
cannot go for this so on yeah what what
I think it's important from a practical
point of view is that um even though
white white had gotten himself into some
trouble after Iran moved 10 moved 12
something that is still as comfortable
on advantage he on the clock yeah so
very often you see people who was sort
of recognized okay this game is not
going my way Afghan many problems why
why did I get myself into this mess and
so on and while I've young like this
with yourself you spend lots of time and
also get into [ __ ] trouble but also and
does this was she didn't do at all he
just played quickly but also be six is a
problem for Bishop f6 and Bishop e7 here
as well that we double attacking and
trying to get to this d6 yeah why has
some some clear card to play now hmm so
that has to be kind of factor than now
so rook e8 yeah his Kings get the rocks
off now maybe because of something like
that Bishop f6 anyway hitting g5
important is just just quickly to show
very important is that white cannot
exchange on yeah yeah I mean you can but
it's a bit it's a bit risky because
you've got you for coming up g fool but
how oh yeah and then tight with the king
yeah let's let's say stuff like this
here in check and then you've got F for
coming up all right
I think like it's on the verge of
winning so need to need to be cautious
you know maybe there is some rescue or
whatever but you shouldn't shouldn't
really get into this you okay um so he
played the ship to f6 he m mmm so in
turn soju after all okay check check
King takes check now night age to check
okay so the question is here can the
King actually carry on its journey at
Sage free I think it may not have been
able to there's a reason um it goes no
it does bother me yeah questions no I
think I'd f3 yeah it goes don't afree
all right he's now threatening um uh
he's first there was some threat in this
position yeah the problem is black would
like to be active again but check this
lose us out right oh yes I seasick fi ya
so it ought to defend a end stuff like
this in the e7 yeah and use your your
bishop just gobbles of all the porns
yeah why just one sees it that's the
reason yeah so this yeah otherwise he
might have gone to oops he might have
gone to let's go to the gym again he
might go kingi to but he cannot so I
black doesn't have a move freely oh
that's unfortunate and some aggressive
use of the King otherwise isn't that
very impressive yeah okay I'll not hats
on this see I saw this so I for joins us
off do something ok a difference this is
like quite good quite good description I
think it doesn't just wants to activate
the bishop and trying to confuse a bit I
think actually though I think someone
said as if white solves the problems
permanently here with site bishop no
maybe not Bishop g5 okay
come there was a positional fret here as
well of maybe night maybe night g5 check
and then taking on 87 as possible as
well off the tape down here yeah that's
very much possible all right let's have
a look at this f4 though so okay so porn
sack or something so he does take the
pawn okay the bishops now okay Liberator
the bet but um and f4 looks weak and it
looks okay the Kings going to get
material back it looks like but then we
see night g5 and unfortunately here
there's a nasty fork if if black does
play King takes then there's rook takes
and then night e 6 check winning that
bishop on a fade and just a second I'm
striving just brought it down the vodka
cost you everything yeah I see shake I
was king of 50 yes you have this move
here but one problem is let's set a this
one what does Fleck dunno blimey that
bishop is silly isn't it it's a very
very silly piece this is like as age six
this if I suppose if h6 you just play
Bishop h4 yeah this is no winning even
it isn't it where's that Bishop guys
yeah oh ok yeah so interesting yet so
that that's pretty dangerous that I did
it's tricky yeah so I wonder what did
you play actually so rook I ate he plays
Rock a night and now we see Brooke III
so here now if takes here I think um he
didn't take the knee he play king at
night I think you just cannot well then
there's check transition seven isn't
that um yeah also also this the shine of
stuff you can are out you can just leave
in a couple of checks here
ah yeah and let's say this one and you
Bishop a strap yeah it's like the shoes
on the other foot you know for a bishop
in the previous game on on ba we've got
a source official on f8 here in this
game yeah ya know this yeah somehow it
shows that really this position was
opened up prematurely and why does God
all active pieces yeah and this is hmm
this is what you don't want okay it's
it's it's what's tricky it's not wasn't
easy yeah k12 f5 yeah we saw Bishop
going back okay I fall finally pay for
something there but night e six okay
Bishop 86 still looks a little bit
dangerous because it's pointing at White
King potentially but the night the
lights holding things together quite
well on he sings yeah and the best that
blacken can sort of get us some some
opposite color to end game yeah that
wouldn't be so nice if he wants to win
yeah yeah exactly so it's very
comfortable that why only needs to draw
here and also now you see this the sound
eternal weakness on d6 yes so Bishop e7
is um yeah exactly there should be seven
or bishop h4 g3 something like this oh
yes even better yes part the bishop
potentially that's even better yeah cuz
I makes that more slowly as well yeah
exactly just according to the specific
position one of those two root two ideas
and black needs to cover this porn all
the time you cannot in any way consider
to two sacrifices as if this porn Ford's
all other pots fall yes yes all these
friggin that pawn chain is gonna be
undermined with the v7 over d6 dropping
yeah so no beef reso Bishop e7 a major
front again yeah I think by now white is
already somewhat better but okay he just
needed to draw so it didn't try hard to
to maybe make something out of this so
Bishop a fool
okay so he's preventive Bishop e7 that
move but now the bishop comes here to
torture d sinks a bee check check okay
check check check and okay if but
White's holding his pawn chain from be
free with this rug and he comes back to
the phone that seems d6 here but now
every kicking that Bishop it goes to be
one yeah this is not very nice
configuration if you see this the
fourth-ranked is completely covered so
black skin cannot enter and you have
easy accessible to be 6 attacking the
spawn yes ya know this so really this
girl's the end to all blacks ambitions
here mmm if black could win this porn
then maybe the chain collapses like this
but he's getting spawn to take care of
ya and whiter can now help with this
King this King actually can defended the
be born well black skin cannot have been
defending d6 oh yeah this is the problem
so King c1 age for trying to get access
to maybe f4 yeah this is so come talk to
her yeah to make it wrong but there's a
good tactic here which says viddler saw
immediately predicted this beautiful
calculation wise viddler not not caring
about this position too much if he moves
wrote it could be in trouble if he has
to move the rope but he doesn't have to
be a beautiful move I fall artists in
fight it to guarantee the draw yeah
Bishop f5 is just the draw the drawing
wolf where you can move the Rockets not
not not a big deal hmm um you can I
think wouldn't it wouldn't you a little
g5 is super clear of course yeah germs
of drawing the game yeah so he's just
going to tell you it's just a real
component in
with his rook on these spots lost love
haha that's the kind of position you
really draw against anyone yeah and
that's that's it black can no longer do
anything his Kings cut off the force
fields put up to the king and train and
d6 is tying down this rook oh it's
miserable okay well well done too vishy
anand should we have a quick overview
and summary of this game yeah sure so an
interesting choice of opening bypassing
mainline check nidal free this Bishop b5
again even without knight c6 so this
break in the center is in quite
interesting and blackjack got the bishop
pair and with Queen a6 seem to have
quite an annoying position and maybe as
you say the most dynamic opportunity no
towel will do this one knee to try and
get to the king in the sense he wouldn't
want the Queen's off here woody tell you
wanna get ya long castle is very very
dynamic again very interesting I think
um most attacking players would do that
wouldn't they um because they've got
reaction would be but there might be
some concrete stuff I mean I had to add
the engine switched on not briefly there
was some idea where white can you cruel
eyes also huh but I think invested some
time it's not like he immediately
recaptured on d6 I think he he thought
about this yeah and you need to see this
this this end game that they got there
was just better food like I mean he
misplayed it after water yeah check his
King just got involved maybe check he
had an aggressive ambition with his
Kings come on the glide on the light
squares once white play G free it seems
the king was going to be really super
aggressive and a hero maybe but it was
quite a liability as well at the same
time this fi was very committal and
without a rooks offers you say one pair
of rooks it seems white had potential
can't play immediately threatening
Bishop g7 there and it looks as though
black king was always getting in
double for a while here the way it had
to come up the board actually if it does
successfully come up the board it's
gliding through these light square
weaknesses but I wish she had f8 as a
tactical target but in many variations
coming up so the King couldn't venture
to exactly after the check it had to UM
it couldn't go to g2 because of this
this check here very very neat idea
isn't it this yeah I think it's hidden
he he very nicely captured editors
chinita see he needed to capture dead
there's a couple of months ago otherwise
white is toast yeah this this because
this if he loses this he's losing this
is being yeah and then this would go in
the nice diagonal and then that would be
terrible and then you will have a bishop
you need to have those those tricks and
if you don't you just lose the game so I
think you need to see this couple of
moves and once this idea so f for which
which does at least liberate the Bishop
of Bath some now while still getting a
grip on things because of this month of
the night now installing itself on e6
pretty soon which takes care of a few
issues and and helps to get the opposite
Bishop color and make sure after okay
six there was nothing much else with
that bishop doesn't want to go back
miserably to fa does it so um no man
also there might be some made ideas even
if a black would play Bishop fa dumb
stuff like f3 and rook g3 g5 checkmate
oh yeah I just get the King yeah yeah
yeah it's not like this wins immediately
but now you cannot be sure the Vedas
ridiculous so try to win but ya know
that's just not enough yeah enough
firepower on the bottle f'd so the idea
is to get to this d6 there are roots in
to get to d6 which is like a classic
weakness in the Benoni isn't it the
baloney son of storoe opening you get d6
as a major weakness so now it's been
targeted like this check my efficiently
check when we get this situation check
these checks aren't so brilliant because
the route has to go back and we get now
a very neat tactical move in response to
this other porn sack to get access to
wear for the king is sucked back to g5
touch me to a raw rook and pawn anything
where the king is cut off totally and
the rooks tied down d 6 so a really nice
way to force a draw in the end I thought
okay so yeah thanks Chris I hope
everyone got everything from this
commentary and the commentary and
overall in the match the dual kanji so
yeah so from from my quad thanks for
watching and also father on comments
left on the channels yeah I'm very very
nice to get some feedback on this and
help we did a good coverage here I've
been quite a number of games in the end
quite some project and I think we really
are yeah shot some pretty nice detailed
analysis on this yeah alright thanks
okay thanks everyone comments or
questions on youtube on both on channels
kingscrusher and chance explained thanks
very much